le candidat de la france insoumise
va-t-il surfer sur la vague de jean luc
mélenchon dans la 11e circonscription
avec près de 25% des voix lors du
premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle le candidat insoumis
arrive en tête à trappes avec plus de 32
% des suffrages pour défendre le projet
de l'avenir en commun mathurin lévis se
lance dans les législatives le score de
jean luc mélenchon sur la
circonscription c'est un très bon
résultat
ça prouve qu'il ya sur cette
circonscription des milliers de citoyens
qui sont convaincus qu'il faut que notre
société empreinte un grand changement
économique social politique écologique
etc
donc il faut capitaliser sur ces
électeurs là tous les électeurs qui ont
voté pour jean luc mélenchon au premier
tour de l'élection présentielle retrouve
un bulletin de vote de la france a
soumis ce qui porte ce projet politique
invité d'honneur pour analyser les
résultats de l'élection présidentielle
le sociologue emmanuel todd pour lui
l'électorat de la france insoumise est
interclassiste les quartiers populaires
mais pas seulement sa vraie force et là
c'est d'être effectivement c'est
essentiel d'avoir une prise sur les
quartiers populaires
mais si on veut aller quelque part il
faut avoir une prise sur les catégories
intermédiaires sur les classes moyennes
est l'une des caractéristiques de
l'électorat béland chant c'est sa
jeunesse
donc je pense qu'il faudrait croiser les
variables de profession et d'âge pour
comprendre exactement ce qui se passe
deux inquiétudes pour mathurin lévis la
gauche part divisée en quatre
candidatures et le niveau de
l'abstention dans les quartiers
populaires pour les élections
législatives de 2012 elle avait atteint
plus de 43 % des inscrits dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines